Ngày 2020 tháng 3 năm 1 in chính trong 4 miệng, tại Nguyenhà số 5 miếng tảm hẳn ngàn khả nội,
chủ tịch hối chi Minh đã chở tập và chủ chỉ phía hoặc ban thường vụ Trung Quân đang,
bàn những dựng vụ cấp bách của nhấn nước cách mạnh.
Trong cuộc họp lịch sửa, người nhất chỉ với chủ triân của ban thường vụ,
mở giống thành phần Ui Bán xâm tập dài phóng và sớm công vụ sân xác của Ui Bán cho toàn dân biết,
chuẩn bị bàn tuyên môn được lập và tổ chức quốc nít tình lớn ở Hàn Hội,
để Ui Bán xâm tập dài phóng xà mắt quốc dân. Ngày xà mắt quốc Ui Bán cũng là ngày Việt Nam
tuyên bố thành lập chính thế gián chủ cộng hoa.
Cũng trong ngày này, tổng thình nghĩa tiếp tục dành tháng lợi ở nhiều địa phương,
2 miệng vạn nhân dân cần thơ bị tình, tuyên bố chính quyền về tài cách mạnh.
Tại cho đất viên hoa, con gái, lực lượng cách mạnh, lượng rộng nội dài,
kể thơ phụ tràng, chấm lĩnh thành lập chính quyền cách mạnh.
Ờ tháng quyền, Việt mình cũng bộ quân nhật giúp khỏi thị sả,
bàn ráo toàn bộ bụ khí cho kẻ mạnh.
Những sự kẻa ấy đã có phần quan trọng tạo thế và lực,
để làm nên ngày 1, 2 tháng chính lực sợ,
đưa ra tục Việt Nam chính thức đất sàng kiện quyền độc lập tự gió.